alex is going to introduce himself
because he can do a much better job at
it than I can so Alex hi everybody I
will see you all in 150 slides so can
you see everything ok good my name is
Alex and some people will let me do a
talk here at PyCon and so here I am I
used to do security instead of
responsible Essien but lately I've been
doing red teaming which is like
sponsored crimes and it's been really
fun and today I'm gonna talk to you
about some things I'm also I also I've
also agreed to like help organize this
conference I called purple cone and I've
agreed to help organize it because I'm
young and invincible recently no
recently a few years ago now some I
write about some like crimes that I did
and some people with some journalists
write about that blog post and they said
Oh according to a blog post by a hacker
who goes by the name Alex and they put
it in quotes and so alex is my I was my
real name also and so so this is my this
is my hacker name now um you can call me
that I can't stop you I'm about to talk
about i'ma talk I'm about to talk about
hacking my friend like a real friend
like an actual friend of mine he's like
a real person and not made up and so
like in case any of you having the
genius idea that you should hack your
friends um don't do that you it's not
good it's not a good thing to do the
only reason it's okay that I did it is
because I explicitly asked them like DK
is it ok if I try and hack you do you
understand what it means like a you sure
you want to take the risks and so on and
so on and this person said yes anyway
this is my friend Anna dad it's not her
real name that's not a real picture this
whole thing is like a lie but it's what
it's not a lie that she really did say
it's ok for me to try and echo and
explain what all that is and so some
things about her that you're gonna need
to know is that she's a comedian that's
her job
and she's sweet and young and tech
literacy is normal she like all you
people here at PyCon probably know more
about technic imputed sin she does she
knows the normal man for someone her age
and so I like for some reason she said
yes by the way if she was like the first
person I asked and I was ok but ok if I
try and hack all your stuff and she was
like yeah and I was much easier than I
thought it would be and so I made some
rules about like ok
well they're just gonna be no rules
maybe so what what what constraints are
we gonna have and so I have 12 months to
do it I can do any time in the 12 months
I'm not allowed to delete anything so
I'm glad to add stuff and look at stuff
but no I was like what if I deleted your
emails and she was like oh that would be
bad okay you can't do that and also I'm
not allowed to disrupt her daily life so
this means like if I were to lock her
out of her email account by like
changing the password then that'd be bad
because she needs her email account to
like do things cuz I was to like had a
notice then post stuff on her Facebook
wall then like that would be bad cuz
she'd be like distracted by that it's a
like not like interrupt her
inconvenience her because she's my real
life real friend also I decided that I'm
just gonna do this whole thing without
getting caught because that's what it
sounds like anyway and also I'm not
allowed to exploit the fact that I know
her in real life so I can oh like email
address and phone number and where she
lives and all this stuff I'm gonna not
use that information I'm gonna do it as
if I was a real hacker okay oh so that's
right this talks about operation the
wages of the picture Luigi at the
beginning you might be wondering why is
this called operation Luigi in the
interest of time let's get straight to
it the first thing we have to do is find
out what our email address is even
though we already know we have to find
it and so I was like okay well I'm using
this advanced hacking software okay just
put her name into it and the word
LinkedIn and LinkedIn just tells me he's
whatever email addresses because
LinkedIn encourages you hey put your
email address on LinkedIn so people can
find you people like me not really
mostly recruiters but also people like
me I noticed it's a hotmail email
address and I'm like oh maybe this is
wrong maybe this is old
cuz like no one's easy hotmail still are
they and so but so then I went to
Twitter I wanted to know whether this
was oh really my main email address I
went to Twitter and if you try and reset
your password on Twitter it will say
sure you can reset your password we're
gonna email a link to and then it will
give you most of the email address so
give you a few letters and the domain
and I was like cool this means this is
that this means hot my one is a current
email address weird people whether she's
still using hotmail address but okay
also this is screenshot as old this
doesn't happen anymore but it doesn't
let you do this anymore right if you go
and research if I put on Twitter right
now it'll be like sure you can reset
your password type in the email address
that you use to log in to this Twitter
account tell us the email address and
then we'll give you
presumably to prevent this so good stuff
Twitter okay so now after getting a
phone number I think by the way I'm not
this is my first time like hacking
someone anything and so I'm like I don't
really know what I'm doing but I've seen
other people do it at conferences so I'm
like I think I just need to collect
everything that can be collected about
this person first then somehow it'll
somehow hacking happen and so I'm like
okay he's okay I got an email address
enough with the word phone into my
advanced hacking software i've actually
obscured the name of the acting so first
you can't tell which one it is because
it's so powerful and so i do this and
there's like a page and just says like
hey do you wanna sign up to this club
because she's like the header of some
sort of club and says contact ana at
this email address this phone number cuz
like she just put it on the on line
because she wanted to be found and said
like this was not i'm not saying she's
dumb or bad for doing this this is
totally normal right you have to have
some sort of privacy trade-off if you're
going to like advertise yourself which
is what you need to do if you're
organizing a club or anything so like
well what can you do about that right if
you want to organize a club you got to
put some sort of contact information on
the internet works for me and so now I'm
like okay what do I do have the have the
him out dress in for a number what do I
do now
okay maybe I should I went to a lot of
conferences and they say you have to
email someone a word document with
macros in it and then I click the macros
and then you have control of the
computer and I was like okay well I
don't know how to do that also did she
even have a live talk maybe just has a
phone also like if I got control of the
computer then what would I do that what
would I would probably just try and get
her browser cookies and log into her
cloud stuff anyway so maybe I don't
actually want control of the computer
maybe I wasn't how like I like email and
passwords and stuff and so okay I'm not
gonna do this this is too hard
maybe I can just maybe I'll try and hack
into email first and then I can decide
what to do
because email is kind of like you know
the the the keys to the kingdom sort of
the top of everything if you can act we
can get in someone's email then you can
use it in order to reset their Twitter
and reset the other stuff from getting
to other other accounts I'm gonna try
and go for that this is what this is
what I justified this to myself it was
late at night whatever okay so now I
have to get her email password note that
I can't get into her email any other way
I have to actually know her email
password and type it in and log in at
the same time as her because if I got
into an email any other way by like
pretending to be here and resetting it
she would get kicked out of it so she
has to also still be in her email and
all
know that I haven't also been email so
the only way I can do this is by just
get in the password which is where I'm
try and do there's this great website
for getting passwords called hammer
being owned owned a lot of controversy
on how to pronounce that and you let's
you put an email address and we'll tell
you which of the like public data
breaches they called that email address
appears in so you can put in your email
and it will tell you yeah like LinkedIn
got hacked in 2012 and your email was in
there so some hacker has your LinkedIn
password and will tell you that for all
the different sites that have been act
then that they want all the different
ones that this Web site knows about
clever nowhere does it say that you need
to put in your email address so very
cleverly I put in her email address and
I find that she's in at the time of
writing she was only in she was in a few
the only interesting ones were patreon
and tumblr patron didn't have passwords
tumblr was the only one that had
passwords in there like how to breach
thing okay cool I know my friends like
password is on the internet now I know
it's on this it's in this tumblr breach
thing this is great so now the tumblr
password dump is something that I just
happen to have lying around and so it
looks like this it's a big text file and
it's just got the email address and then
a colon and the password hash and
hackers are not very good at documenting
their stuff and so they don't really say
what kind of password hashes they are
it's a text file I looked around the
internet and people seem to think that
their sha-1 hash is for the static salt
and am i cool what does that mean and so
let me explain what a static salt is so
imagine you're like I don't know a web
site let's call them tumblr and you're
storing like emails and passwords this
is one way you could do it you could
store the email address of the person
and you could also destroy their
password because then when they log in
you know whether they typed in the right
password cuz you have the password but
then you go to a security conference and
they tell you you know about to do that
so okay actually you know hash the
passwords so this way you don't store
the password you stole this like
scrambled up version of it and then you
can think you don't have to check and
you don't have to keep a copy of the
user's password but you can still check
whether they type the right password in
so okay now inserting the password
hashes in you're like am i doing it now
then people at security conferences are
like no it's not good enough you need to
do the salting thing now and so now you
need to before yes before you hash the
password you need to add a random string
to the end of it just in case somebody
has a big list of the hash of every
possible like eight character string
that they could possibly use that to
like reverse what your hash was back
into the password so you have to add
this salt thing to the end and so you go
okay okay and so now you're adding this
salt and you add to it all the end of
the passwords like this this is called a
static salt and static means it's the
same for all the passwords and so now
you're adding the same thing to the end
of every single password and the point
of this is to prevent somebody with a
big list of the hash of every single
string from using that big list to
reverse your password hashes but do you
see the problem here the problem is that
these two these two users have the same
password and because we're adding the
same thing to the end of the password
the same stat the same static so the
thing that's getting hashed is the same
throughout these people in fact they're
gonna have the same password if and only
if they have the same password hash and
so even when we hash everything you can
see the HTTP at least your users have
the same password hash you don't know
what it is you don't know what the
password is
but you know these two people have the
same password because of aesthetics old
thing so why am I telling you all about
the aesthetics old thing it's because I
don't know what the stuff is for the
tumblr password dump even though it's
the salts not going to be a secret thing
it's meant to be like public it's meant
to be as public is likely user names but
I don't know what it is because it's not
included in the text file because
hackers are not good at documenting
their stuff so I'm like okay I really
want to I really want to get my friends
password out of this but I don't know
how so the first thing I did when I had
the list was that search for my friend's
email address and I'm like okay email
address I'll get all the wines that have
her email address it which is just the
one with a password hash in it am i cool
but don't know what this don't know what
this password hash goes to I don't know
what password this password hash is of
so here's the sneaky thing I do I
searched for her password hash in the
file not her password just share
password hash like an absolute madman
because what do you think weapon what do
you think we happen when I type in there
like when I prefer - it should just be
one like it should just be her line
right you just have my friend Ana's
thing it's like 20 people who have the
the same have the same password - right
and these people is like a little past
my book club right they can all get
along
these least fun this fun little book
enthusiasts all have the same password
on tumblr and so this tells me a few
things
um probably it's not a very good
password since all these people have
thought of the same one but again I'm
very smug about don't know what it is so
I need to find out what it is and so
here's what I do I get just the email
addresses of those people in the
password book club I throw away the
password ashes then I know what to do
with the hash just get those email
addresses these are all the people who
have the same password as Diana and then
conveniently did you know that LinkedIn
was also hacked in 2012 and danezaa Bano
is not in this list because she didn't
have lead in 2012 but lots of people
were and thanks to the hard work and GPU
cycles of people in the password
cracking community almost all those
LinkedIn passwords are in plain text now
they're not just hashes their emails and
like you know just passwords you can
just look at with your eyes and I was
like wow I also just happen to have that
lying around and so then I did this
thing where I looked up the same people
who in the password book club in the
tumbler list in the LinkedIn list and I
found most of them not all them about
80% of them had the same password as
each other on LinkedIn as well
so isn't that really sweet that their
book club transcends like services and I
have a suite and I found that most of
them had the password QWERTY one and so
this is a bit of it there's a bit of
like a bit of a jump here I'm guessing
that my friend diana has the same
passwords like people on tumblr
okay I'm not guessing that's definitely
true and then I'm guessing that they all
have the same password on LinkedIn and
then I'm guessing that that password is
this most frequent one that's quite a
QWERTY one thing I'm guessing that
that's damaged password and I'm like
okay I've done it let's go
QWERTY once times fast word I did it I'm
hacking let's go it's time to use this
thing I gotta hop me I'll type it in and
it's not the right password like that
photo out my password it was that was it
wasn't it I was like well damn why did I
do all this work why did I go to all
these great lengths okay whatever so
then I go to Facebook and I said just
try it on hear me I'll try it on
everything I got a face broke and it
says oh no that's my facebook password
but it's an old password it was your
password about five months ago
oh thanks Facebook for taunting me I
guess I'm too late
but I mean like okay so this did used to
be a password she just happens to have
changed it recently and I've somehow
stumbled upon the person it has more
than one password in their life
okay fine I guess we're just the hard
way which is but I didn't want to have
to do so by the way this this is what I
had planned this is what I thought this
like hacking would be like I was gonna
be like hi it's so easy to hack someone
you just look them up and all these
lists that you have lying around and
it's a Visia vet and so the rest of this
talk will be about how it's not as easy
as that always and so I'm like okay I
guess I'm gonna try and do this fishing
thing I'm gonna try and trick her into
sending me the password because everyone
else is doing it it's more work it's
more it's more work because you have to
make something custom but like oh well I
don't know is this how you do fishing I
don't know it's my first time maybe I
should be something like this
I don't know you don't know that it you
don't know that it won't work so no I'm
not gonna do that gonna do this here's
the hit the plan to come up with I'm
gonna send her a fake email from
Microsoft cuz she has hot mails it has
to be Microsoft and that email gonna
take you to a login screen hotmail but
it's a fake login screen that actually
sends me a password and then she'll go
to the real hotmail login screen and
just kind of keep going as if nothing
happened this is my plan I don't know
don't whatever and so um but to do this
I'm gonna need to make a hotmail account
to send the email front so i go to i go
to make a hotmail account which will let
me open a world of benefits and i try to
make one that looks like Microsoft I try
to make a Microsoft account team and
says no you can't do that presumably
because the word Microsoft is in the
email address and they know I'm not
Microsoft and so I try to make my first
name Microsoft on my last name account
team and they're like no you can't do
that and presumably to stop exactly what
I'm trying to do and fair enough however
these are my round friends and there
they look like two O's don't they looks
like I've put two O's in the slide like
an absolute fool but actually one of
them is in home and one of them is a
Greek letter Omicron which looks a lot
like a note to you and me doesn't it but
to a computer they're completely
different like unicode code points and
so like if you dispel microsoft's like
this with these only ones then like that
doesn't say Microsoft but like to you
and me it looks like it does
and so like does this really work I'm
sure you're wondering
surely like surely the billions of
dollars at Microsoft and the most
advanced minds I'm gonna be full bite no
does why I can't does and so I make this
I make this Microsoft account team thing
and I sent her this email which says a
lot I copied this from like a real
Microsoft email that I got I copied all
their like styling and most of the text
and it says oh you better to log into
your account in the next 48 hours over
gonna luck it oh please do it or it's
gonna be real bad oh boy there's like
Russians IP addresses you wouldn't want
that
I don't know and so it says like coming
log in please but again this is just an
email alert like that link but that
don't workers account thing at the
bottom that has to be a link to
something and so I need to make that I
need to make a website for that bottom
button to link to sorry okay let's go
this is the real login screen you know
it was at the time and so I'm gonna I
need to make a copy of this and so
there's an easy way to make copy of
things with this hacking tools
technique I learned about when stuff
watch everything that's before have step
one if you right-click on something step
two Z hit this button and when you hit
that inspect element button that's the
good stuff
I think there are easier ways to copy
websites but I always do it this way
anyway so here's my copy of the website
it looks the same because it is the same
but this time it's on my computer it's
on localized and so now you need to put
on the internet somehow hence so I'm
like how do I put this
I can't only hit a local host had I put
this online and I found this like static
hosting company website thing they're
not paying me to say this but that well
I could they let you Mike house static
files in the internet and this is really
good because you get a custom subdomain
so you can be anything aerobatic tayo
they give you HTTP for free and it's
like to command something to do it and
no one knows about it so all the good
subdomains aren't taken so like I'm sure
it's a good static hosting site but it
happens to also be a really good fishing
hosting site so thank you to these
people you can use the promo code Diana
to be immediately reported to the
authorities
this is the one I made this is the the
you know the domain I chose the real
hotmail logon screen it's log the real
hotmail login domain is login live.com
and so I could have like made my own
domain name and like I made it look even
more similar but I just don't think the
Hanna's gonna look at the euro very much
because she's not like a paranoid
security president like us but then
again for some reason logging when you
go to like a login screen the Euro
doesn't look like that it looks like
this it has a bunch of like stuff at the
end and so I just added a bunch of stuff
at the end
okay it doesn't do anything actually
stole from the Google logon screen but
whatever okay it's my first time and so
here it is this is my fake login screen
on the internet now I know it's the same
picture but this time with me internet
trust me and so I also add these bonus
features to it the first one is that
after she clicks the the login button
the submit button it's gonna add an
image to the page and the image goes to
a website I control forward slash Diana
and then question mark and then plus
whatever her password is so the reason
I'm doing this is to try and steal
whatever I was just trying to steal I
pass well this is like a terrible awful
way to do it you probably shouldn't do
it was really easy so like I'm gonna get
a request to my website and forward
slash Diana and then plus some password
and I don't know what this password is
so it's gonna be a 404 but then in my
logs it's gonna be a request for a 404
to data and then the password
somebody's gonna be looking at my logs
for this Diana thing when it shows up
I'll be like oh that's the password and
then I make it so that after she clicks
the button it wait - one second and then
goes to the real hotmail login screen
the one second way to simulate
Australian internet speeds anyway here's
email I send it's like you know look out
it's something your Bad's gonna happen
and you really got 48 hours because I'm
creating time pressure when I'm doing
all the good stuff I've seen random
phishing emails - then I kind of just
want us to work so come on click click
the link and so I sent it to her and
said she Anastasia 48 hours then 24
hours later nothing happened I'm looking
at my logs and she'd snot there I'm like
she hasn't worked on it yet and so I'm
like ok so I sent the email again saying
like same thing but now you're there 48
hours 24 hours you better click it and
then 48 hours later she also I'm like oh
okay alright like at this point I'm not
actually hacking anyone I'm just
emailing my friend I'm like okay that's
a shame I guess it wasn't interesting
enough email and fair enough and the
thing I learned from this is that people
don't really care about emails from
Microsoft or about like emails from like
like automated emails they care about
emails from people which leads me to the
next way I try and do this which is like
okay she's gonna be like on the internet
whatever its you're gonna get an email
from a recruiter and the recruiter is
gonna link her to another fake - the
same fake login page and then you're
gonna go to a Google Doc and the login
page you don't make a login to see a
Google Doc is such but this is Microsoft
it's a hotmail Google Docs is there such
thing as Microsoft Google Docs so I look
it up if this is the other thing is that
a real thing and there is and it's
called clouds guys something something
something something something and so
great and so I log into this and make oh
no I think I make the make the document
in something else and then copy and
paste it into this and so now I have in
Microsoft Google Doc and what document I
made I made it resume like I fake fake
but convincing looking resume and then I
send her on it before I do that I have
to make the person he's gonna send it to
her I can't email her for me can't email
from Microsoft the canteen so I guess
it's gonna have to be from this a
present
and so I go to the login screen you know
you put whatever you want in these boxes
it's very good and so I make this
present called Kathleen wheeler dude is
like a mix of a first name and last name
from a real company that I found and
then I send to this which says this is
me writing this sometimes sound like I'm
a recruiter I don't know what it sound
like and I'm saying hey I work at this
company company which you care about and
which I looked up early on LinkedIn and
somebody has listed you as a reference
somebody has told us that you work
together like somebody has said that
they worked with you here's the resume
tell us how you know them logo I click
here for the resume that link it's
obviously the one that goes to the fake
login screen and then after a lot of
text being like can you fill out this
form and tell us these things and blah
blah blah that says to distract from the
link and then it says also can can you
let me a good time to call you is the
phone number her phone number which I
found earlier
okay the reason I put a phone number
there so she knows this is like for her
it's not like an accident like was
present clearly knows who she is and
then I've made a sweet email signature
at the bottom with like a different fun
and everything I thought I was really
good attention to detail or whatever and
so I send this to her and it totally
works like she clicks into time Center
password is like the whole thing just
works flawlessly and I was like wow that
was really easy and then I was a little
bit closer and
wait a minute this password that she
sent me that's query one that's I
already have that one I got authority
that's already sounds like what that's
how could that did I do something wrong
and then I was like no way even his
rival and she does not know it is which
which which in many ways is the ultimate
defense against people so like don't
don't don't shame it for this but also
because my fake login screen will just
say yes no matter what possible you type
in actually think this is a yeah and I'm
like whoops I hope I can fix that
offenses all over anyway
so instead of giving up I update my
login screen so now no matter what you
type in it just says wrong password the
first three times because my theory is
that people who like memorize all their
passwords they just try Weinman it
doesn't work I'm going to try the other
one and the other one they just unload
all their passwords into the form and so
I also change it so if you try it QWERTY
one the counter doesn't go up so you
can't just quit he won three times and
so then then I send her out then she
replies and she's like no I haven't work
with this person which is true cuz I
didn't exist and then she's like you can
call me here's my friend number and I'm
not gonna call her because I'm not kept
with him I'm like the fire being like
oops that was wrong residue off for some
reason you better click on this up this
makes no sense right like like if you
think about this like if you stop and
think about this oh there's another
person you also work with you around the
same time but with different dates that
I and I think you they resume instead of
the other but it doesn't make any sense
right like the story doesn't work but it
has the same like bait of like somebody
says they know you and you have to click
to find out who and so I'm like you know
please please do click on it anyway
please I know and you know it's miss
time same thing happens she clicks on it
and gee I typed in thing she types the
same thing three times which is this
other password which looks a lot like 21
also not only for the real but they're
similar to what they actually were those
ones I've shipped it along by one in the
keyboard I'm like hmm okay what's this
password and so I got a hot meal and
like using my advising the advanced
hacking software Google Chrome type the
password into the out my login screen
and press enter and it totally works
I get into email Mike it's as easy as
that everybody
see it's simple okay so then I got an
email password but now what do I do like
I tried the same password on everything
and it doesn't work I'm like great this
person has three passwords in their
lives and then she applies being like no
I haven't work with this person either
why are you doing this what what's
happening and I replied just being like
don't worry about it
don't stress about it you know I'll just
handle it do it please do anyway anymore
please just forget about this and she
does she doesn't reply so I'm like great
I mean while I look into email and I
click on the I want to search for more
password so I can look into more stuff
and so I click on the search bar thing
and it shows me her last five searches
oh my ghoul but the last five searches
aren't anything interesting and but I
want to search for like password and
other things but if I do it then you'll
see there's you know search history
right so I write down the last five
things she searched for and then search
for all my stuff and then search for
those things in Reverse so it looks
exactly the same because I'd only shows
the last five Microsoft knows what I've
done but I'm doing anyway and it would
totally works but I didn't find any
passwords because I don't know I found a
lot of pot roads already had I didn't
find any passwords I was like fine
whatever
so this is the end of the talk I guess
that's it I mean or email never believe
it when it says the end question mark no
it's an artisan at the end geez this
talk is called operation at this talk is
called operation Luigi and I'm like
already in my friend's email you know it
would be a real shame to just kind of
leave it at that you know we really aim
to not like do anything with that so
here's what operation love Ouija is kids
we need to do four things get into our
Twitter second thing is to not lock her
out of it to it because she needs to be
in there too and also don't let her know
that I'm in know stuff don't know that
I'm a nerd with her um so here's how I
do it
I go to Twitter and I'd be like hey I
forgot my password and - let me reset it
and like you know because I mean her
email now in a second we said the
password cuz it'll send me the email and
I can click it and I can do that now as
I change her Twitter password - QWERTY
one and so
that's because this is the password that
I think she thinks so fast what is and
delete all the emails and blah blah
white petal again and cuz I need her to
login so I know that she's actually type
21 and she's back in her an account and
I wait a while and then eventually she
actually logs in and I'm like great it
was she retweets she we showed a picture
of a dog and I was like yes okay so now
that I did the exact same thing with
LinkedIn as I did with widow and I try
to change the LinkedIn password to
cruddy one as well but doesn't let me
presumably cuz I got the cruddy one from
the link to him password dump something
no it's bad there's a little box at the
bottom which says require all devices to
signing with new password which is like
would you like to sign me out on like
would you like to sign out all your
other devices and I'm like absolutely
not Thank You LinkedIn for giving me
this option unchecked by default so I
can just change the password without
even signing her out I'm sorry I just do
that and then I'll get it
and so okay now what let me explain so
this picture of Obama is here because I
can't show you Dan real pictures I have
to show you because I can't show you her
real profile pictures I'm gonna show you
what I did to her real profile pictures
but with pictures of Obama I don't know
just go with it
and so here's what a Twitter fixture was
and I change it to be like this I don't
know if you can tell there's like
there's like a load there's like a
lightly transparent luigi there and so
also she had a LinkedIn picture and I
change to LinkedIn picture to have like
another
can you see it and so I just left it
there for like I don't know weeks I
don't know okay yeah good weeks and it's
left up there and no one said anything
okay I thought you might have noticed
then but this is sort of like proof that
I got somewhere and so you know nothing
happened okay well this is over this
operation Luigi goes not over the
remainder of this talk will be about
operation wallow idea and you know I
came up with this like a long time ago
back when this meme was like you know
new anyway whatever we do let's go so I
changed her link I changed her LinkedIn
bio to be the entire Wikipedia page for
Luigi I'm gonna do this LinkedIn says
her profile strings is advanced so thank
you
Thank You LinkedIn for being there for
me dis entire talk anyway I change to
Twitter to be lists like I want to make
it super obvious so she I want her to
know that I mean I want I want to be
caught now like I'm trying to be caught
I'm like however noticing him very loud
I tweet this from her account just go
for it and she's online at the same time
because it's like 7 p.m. and she would
fire that she says oMG to this thing and
she says I've been hacked my dudes but
then because I'm also at the same time I
reply as her saying oh he just seemed
like the right thing to do at the time
anyway then actually this actually this
I keep doing things until she messages
me and I treat longing for the days of
this sweet lad and keep tweeting things
eventually she messaged me and be like
oh my gosh my Twitter is this you and
I'm like yes it's me don't worry nothing
Bad's happening and stuff now it's all
congratulations I guess he got me and
here's what happened after that she'll
all I was saying you all the way gee
life so much she goes and changes her
facebook to me waluigi themed even
though i didn't touch it
she's like gets really into waluigi
kocho I'm not gonna read this that like
she like she like really got into it and
she also asked me like wow how do I'm
not get act like how do I what's already
wrong like why we didn't anything wrong
why but like this is kind of a question
of people ask what right people ask
security people like how do I stay safe
what should I be doing online and these
are just like regular people who ask
this like not security people that if
like normally people in a weird like us
and they say oh how do I stay safe and
then sometimes they kind of answers are
here from security people were like oh
you got to do all these things and live
in a submarine and never go anywhere and
you gotta get all this advanced
multi-factor you be keys or whatever and
so like there are other things you can
say you know so Hillary I told her I was
like well listen up to you right like
things you can do to stay safe there are
things you can do they eat like there
are things you can do to stay safe but
they involve investing more time and
effort it's up to you how much you wanna
invest is up to you how much you care
about this maybe you don't care and you
find it getting hacked that's okay
that's a fellow way to live your life
and so I hope her setup two-factor often
ml because I'm about to do this blog
post and publish a guide on how to hack
and so I don't want to be repeatable and
so I hope I said a few factors and I
should get a code and a phone which
it'll be would have been way harder for
me to get passed because there's a way
how did you get past a factor or theater
like I don't know fish the to factor or
thyroid or socially engineer the phone
company too hard and so she was very
happy that it's long bad she was very
happy that she could do this and it
wasn't like much extra for her because
this is like the lowest effort highest
security value thing I think that she
could have done and so she had a little
app like this you know you know how to
back to where she is or what happened
she's like yeah now I can just type in
these codes these backup codes are kind
of a trap though and I kind of warned
about only using the apps because and
see that button that's like you know
saved a text file or keep these codes
somewhere safe
no one clicks those buttons everyone's
just like yeah whatever clothes like no
one keeps these backup codes and so
that's why it's that's one of the
reasons it's good to have SMS as a
backup anyway in conclusion I just
talked about Luigi for like a long time
so I hope you liked it and last thing is
you might be wondering like where did I
get these before I was like oh it had
these lying around every wondering where
did I get the like LinkedIn and tumblr
like possible hashes where did it where
do they actually come from thank you
very much
thank you hello thank you Alex for that
talk we have a lovely cup for thank you
can Melissa sorry ELISA come up to this
stage awesome thanks